the culture secretary oliver dowden has
told the uk mobile operators
to rip huawei kit out of their networks
just five months after they were told it
was okay
to have it in and it's being called a
u-turn but i'm not so sure that's right
it's more like a change in circumstances
about these ships the brains of
computers
modern engineering marvels but also
where power lies in the digital economy
these things are like oil or coal or
natural resources
for technology today so when the u.s
announced in may
that it was changing its rules to stop
huawei buying ships
that was a big change for the uk and
to these guys the uk mobile operators it
put them in a big hole
now the government has given them until
2027 to get rid of huawei kit
but even so this is a major undertaking
because over the last year
all of them but o2 have been quietly
rolling out 5g
with huawei including take a look at
this this is a map of all the locations
in the uk
where we've got 5g and most of them
include huawei
and the telcos were saved a big cost
because the announcement today didn't
require them to remove
huawei from the 3g and 4g networks which
would be a lot more
but it's still going to be difficult for
them which is why the cost of getting
rid of it
is in the billions it's not just a
simple case either of them
going to another vendor like ericsson
and nokia and buying that equipment
overnight and putting it up next week
you know these are lengthy procurement
negotiations that will take probably
12 24 months to complete and then the
disruption associated with visiting tens
of thousands of marks
up and down britain to replace that
infrastructure closing roads and getting
the required planning
it's going to take time and it's going
to be a headache for them
so who's going to replace huawei the
main choice is between ericsson
and nokia but even here there are
difficulties nokia in particular has
lots of kit made in china and the
government hopes it might be able to get
samsung and fujitsu involved
and there is a very interesting plan to
make an open source alternative open ram
but realistically that's years away and
in a way this
sums up the entire problem for the
government its choice to extremely
limited
and the only options